Кожен мешканець Німеччини в середньому має по 5 страховок.
Без якого страхування
у Німеччині не обійтися?
Перш за все - без медичного.
Медичне страхування в ФРН обов’язкове.
Без нього потрапити до лікаря неможливо.
Поліс коштує приблизно 15% від заробітку,
але якщо ви - найманий працівник або службовець,
половину суми сплачує роботодавець.
Більшість пацієнтів навіть не замислюються,
скільки коштує та чи інша медична послуга.
На прийомі в лікаря просто показують картку страхування,
а в аптеках за ліки за рецептом сплачують
фіксовані 5-10 євро. Решту ціни
також покриває страховка.
До обов'язкових страховок у Німеччині
також належить пенсійне страхування,
страхування з безробіття та страхування
на випадок потреби в догляді. Наприклад,
у разі втрати роботи держава протягом року
виплачуватиме 60% зарплати і при потребі оплатить
утримання в будинку для людей похилого віку
чи доглядальницю.
Решту полісів німці укладають добровільно.
Один із найпоширеніших видів -
страхування відповідальності. Йдеться
про компенсацію страховою компанією шкоди,
якої ви мимохіть завдали іншим. Наприклад,
якщо ви зіпсували майно роботодавця,
ваші діти розбили вікно сусідам або ж
ви не прибрали тротуар перед своїм будинком,
а перехожий послизнувся і зламав ногу.
Якщо ви зламали чужий велосипед
або ваша машина заблокувала виїзд
і хтось не встиг на літак, платити відшкодування
теж доведеться не з власної кишені.
Страховка вартістю від 15 євро на рік покриває
в разі доведеної необхідності
мільйонні завдані збитки. Не дивно, що в Німеччині
85% домогосподарств мають цю страховку.
Інший популярний вид - юридична страховка.
Вона дорожча і надає адвоката, який напише за вас
скаргу або захищатиме ваші інтереси в суді.
Окрім того, німці часто мають окреме
стоматологічне або додаткове пенсійне страхування.
Важливою вважається страховка
професійної недієздатності, яка в разі потреби
оплатить перекваліфікацію.
Окрім таких традиційних видів,
як страхування життя, майна, автомобіля
або від нещасних випадків, у Німеччині популярні й
більш екзотичні поліси. Наприклад,
страхування від шкоди, яку може заподіяти
ваш собака чи кінь. Або страхування на випадок
поганої погоди на курорті, адже німці
охоче подорожують і планують відпустки на рік-два наперед,
коли неможливо перебачити, буде зима сніжною
чи доведеться відмовитися від катання на лижах.
Також існує страховка, яка дає право
в останній момент без штрафу відмовитися
від оплаченої поїздки. Інший поліс гарантує
компенсацію, якщо ваш літак запізниться.
Крім того, можна застрахувати свого кота чи папугу,
улюблені меблі, всі вікна у своєму будинку,
мобільний телефон чи окремо окуляри.
Існує страхування навіть від програшу в лотерею.
Якщо ви щотижня будете грати і за рік
жодного разу не виграєте, то отримаєте 2500 євро.